et avec nous pour ce club des
territoires Ariane anémonia animaux
Yanis je vais y arriver bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
étudiante en droit à l'Université pontet
on Sorbonne militante du collectif le
point levé Ambroise mes jambes bonjour
merci d'être là président des Jeunes
avec Macron membre du bureau exécutif de
renaissance Alex et revenu avec nous on
parlera avec vous de la mobilisation
d'une partie de la jeunesse qui est
arrivée dans les cortèges contre la
réforme des retraites que veulent ces
jeunes qui manifestent quelle est leur
profil la contestation est-elle plus
large que la seule réforme des retraites
on va en débattre évidemment avec vous
ce sera tout de suite après l'actualité
dans nos régions on va aller du côté de
Marseille
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Marseille on retrouve les hauts
purgate bonjour Léo merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous président et directeur
éditorial du Journal La Marseillaise
évidemment Marseille qui a été frappé
une nouvelle fois on a envie de dire ce
week-end par l'effondrement de deux
immeubles Léo le bilan est très lourd on
en est où ce matin
oui le bilan est très lourd ciment
toujours deux types parus et donc
effectivement ça la réactive des
souvenirs terribles avec les
effondrements que nous avons connu rue
d'Aubagne mais c'est une situation qui
est très différente car il ne s'agit pas
là d'habitat indigne cela a été une fois
encore confirmé par le ministre du
Logement qui était sur les lieux et il
s'agirait même si l'enquête ne fait que
commencer d'une explosion de gaz qui
serait donc à l'origine de ce drame
effectivement l'enquête ne fait que
commencer les opérations de secours se
poursuivent Léo et puis il y a aussi la
question des nombreuses habitants qui
ont dû être évacués de ce quartier et de
cette rue de Tivoli
tu as fait c'est d'ailleurs l'objet de
l'un de nos reportages aujourd'hui avec
des évacués qu'il faut prendre en charge
d'urgence on estime qu'à peu près la
moitié d'entre eux va pouvoir retrouver
son logement d'ici
demain 30%
assez rapidement et les vins restants
qui sont en réalité ce qui sont
riverains immédiat des immeubles
effondrés et bien eux il faudra sans
doute leur trouver des solutions de
relogement plus durables car on ne sait
pas encore si les bâtiments alentours
sont suffisamment en sécurité pour
pouvoir être réintégrées
à Marseille et la Marseillaise votre
journal s'est mobilisé pour couvrir
cette cette actualité
c'est avec notre journal est très
attaché à la question du logement et
donc nous avons évidemment tout de suite
réagit en allant sur place en étant en
direct sur les réseaux sociaux également
dans notre édition bien sûr de lundi et
dans celle d'aujourd'hui je tiens
d'ailleurs à saluer la mobilisation de
la rédaction et des collègues qui ont
assuré la couverture de cette actualité
qui met aujourd'hui Marseille en deuil
et c'est le titre que vous avez choisi
Marseille en deuil c'est la Une de La
Marseillaise aujourd'hui évidemment de
nombreuses pages à lire dans votre
journal Léo et puis l'autre titre c'est
ce congrès du Parti communiste Fabien ou
celle qui a été réduit après à la tête
du parti communiste pour un nouveau
front populaire voilà double actualité à
lire aujourd'hui dans la Marseillaise
merci beaucoup léo-purgates d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous parler de ce drame
évidemment qui a touché la ville de
Marseille ce weekend on va passer au
débat de ce club consacré à la Mobil de
la jeunesse avant d'en parler avec vous
on va regarder le reportage de Fabien
Ricard puisque fabien a suivi étudiant
et lycéens jeudi lors de la dernière
journée de mobilisation du blocage de
lycée à la manifestation nationale dans
les rues de Paris on regarde
ils sont quelques dizaines ce matin-là a
bloqué l'entrée du lycée Gaston
Bachelard à Chelles en Seine-et-Marne la
plupart de ces lycéens vivent la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites comme une première fois je
m'intéressais pas tellement à la
politique
autour de
m'intéresser du coup plus
à mon avenir j'avais déjà fait des
manifestations pendant que les violences
faites aux femmes ou contre la guerre en
Ukraine des choses comme ça après pour
la réforme des retraites
dans tous les cas j'avais l'envie de
faire de la politique du coup ça
m'intéressait de voir comment c'est les
manifestations pour Maxence comme pour
ses camarades un événement en
particulier a été déclencheur l'emploi
du 49.3 à l'Assemblée nationale je
savais pas ce que c'était au début mais
je trouve que c'est
ils ont fait ça dans notre dos on va
dire ils ne sont pas demandé notre avis
on a l'impression d'être mais à l'écart
parce qu'on est jeune et qu'on est pas
censé s'exprimer mais on va tout savoir
une retraite un jour donc on doit
s'exprimer ce qu'on ressenti au
syndicats la voie lycéenne c'est lui qui
organise le blocus il confirme un effet
49-3 dans la mobilisation 49 3 le
chiffre a doublé voire triplé le chef de
lycéen enfin devant le lycée quoi on a
vu que ça a ramené beaucoup plus de
personnes c'est vraiment en partie à
cause du 49-3 que qu'on est beaucoup
plus qu'avant et c'est lycéens porte
aussi d'autres revendications comme le
retrait du service national universel ou
l'abolition de parcoursup fin de matinée
le blocus est levé les élèves retournent
en classe mais pas où Daifa
avec ses camarades direction la
manifestation parisienne qui doit se
tenir dans l'après-midi
[Musique]
en tête de cortège les lycéens
rejoignent les étudiants un tout petit
peu plus âgé mais tout aussi déterminé à
faire reculer le gouvernement Victoria à
20 ans elle est en troisième année de
droit à l'université parisien
et on a vu qu'il y avait vraiment de
plus en plus de
d'étudiants
[Musique]
j'ai envie de dire normaux qui n'est pas
forcément organisé ou très politisés
avant et qui au fil des événements et
des manifestations sont un peu politisés
j'ai eu plein de copines par exemple de
la fac qui sont qui m'ont appelé pour
venir manifester la première fois savoir
comment il fallait faire etc
de personnes qui se mobilisent de plus
en plus des étudiants qui pour certains
vivent eux aussi leur première grande
mobilisation comme Victor à cause de ses
cours il n'a pas pu aller à toutes les
manifs mais il tenait à venir
aujourd'hui je m'intéressais c'est
à dire que non mais j'avais pas
forcément manifestation
au moment de l'annonce du 49-3 ils ont
osé le faire et c'est vraiment très très
décevant de la part dans le gouvernement
qui dit à l'écoute des jeunes et qui
finalement a jamais été aussi peu à
l'écoute de la population
une jeunesse mobilisée qui s'est déjà
donné rendez-vous le 13 avril prochaine
journée de manifestation contre la
réforme des retraites
[Musique]
de Fabien il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui
se mobilisent pour la première fois qui
ne sont pas forcément politisés que vous
distingue ces jeunes pourquoi cette
mobilisation et qu'a-t-on t-il
finalement
en fait on le voit là dans le reportage
il y a une mobilisation de la jeunesse
qui est
ultra large profonde ça se voit en fait
avec énormément de jeunes qui se
mobilisent pour la première fois ça se
voit avec la mobilisation dans les
universités et les facs école d'élite
comme on dit où on a vu en fait des
blocus à Assas Paris Dauphine à
Montpellier la semaine dernière il y a
la fac de sciences il y avait 700
personnes en assemblée générale donc en
fait ça montre à quel point la
mobilisation elle est profonde elle elle
tend même à s'accroître en fait dans les
universités aussi les lycées depuis la
fin du bac et évidemment que la colère
elle dépasse la réforme des retraites
nous on est mobilisé globalement contre
Macron contre ce gouvernement et si on
prête attention à nos revendications on
verra que tout ce que Macron a fait ces
dernières années nous on veut le défaire
avec cette mobilisation ce dont on parle
en fait dans nos âgés dans nos cortèges
bon déjà c'est de dire Macron démission
c'est ce qu'on chante en fait dans les
cortèges étudiants et lycéens mais c'est
aussi c'est attaqué en fait à la
précarisation des jeunes par le
gouvernement c'est s'attaquer à la
sélection on a entendu parcoursup mais
il y a aussi la réforme trouver mon
Master qui est en fait la même chose
triée et mettre en concurrence les
étudiants à l'entrée des masters il y a
la question du s&u effectivement Macron
il a peur de notre mobilisation donc il
a renoncé peut-être temporairement au
SMU mais en tout cas on va on va revenir
sur tout ça on va revenir sur tout ça et
sur les autres points notamment que la
réforme des retraites je vous laisse
répondre à Ambroise mes gens non mais
moi je veux saluer le fait que les
jeunes s'intéressent et se mobilisent
au-delà des désaccords politiques je
trouve que c'est toujours une bonne
chose peut-être vous faire sourire mais
ma première mobilisation étudiante moi
en tant que jeune engagé c'était contre
la réforme des retraites de Nicolas
Sarkozy en 2010 donc je le comprends je
l'entends très bien et honnêtement je
vécu à leur place vous auriez pu être à
leur place j'aurais pu être à leur place
peut-être plus jeune parce que j'avais
aussi moi aussi cette conscience
politique là qui faisait que j'avais eu
envie de descendre dans la rue
aujourd'hui j'ai changé d'avis sûrement
certains d'entre eux changeront d'avis
sur ce sujet mais je les comprends très
bien et je pense que c'est pas négatif
que la jeunesse se mobilise en tout cas
qu'elle s'intéresse à la vie politique
quel que soit ses opinions et je pense
qu'on sera d'accord là-dessus maintenant
sur le sujet de la réforme des retraites
et du 49-3 je crois qu'il y a aussi un
jeu qui est fait par certains pour
exciter une forme de contestation le
49-3 c'est un dispositif on est sur une
chaîne parlementaire qui est un
dispositif constitutionnel extrêmement
simple le gouvernement a décidé de
mettre la réforme des retraites devant
le Parlement et lui dire est-ce que
cette réforme vous l'accepter oui ou non
si vous ne l'acceptez pas vous votez
contre le gouvernement et vous le
renversez ça aurait pu être fait c'est
d'ailleurs pas passé très loin ce qui
montre qu'il y avait une vraie division
de l'Assemblée nationale avec 9 voies
d'écart seulement mais cette un
processus qui est démocratique puisque
l'Assemblée nationale se prononce le
Sénat s'est prononcé également tout ça
c'est simplement pour déconstruire un
peu le discours et puis après de manière
générale
je peux pas entendre que le Président de
la République n'a rien fait pour la
jeunesse ces dernières années quand vous
avez le taux de chômage le plus bas des
jeunes depuis 40 ans quand vous avez le
niveau d'apprentissage le plus élevé
qu'on n'est jamais connu dans ce pays
quand vous avez le Pass Culture le
passeport quand vous avez la gratuité
des préservatifs quand vous avez la mise
à disposition de protection hygiénique
dans les universités le remboursement
des protections périodiques
renouvelables à partir de l'année
prochaine autant de parler qui sont des
mesures favorables à la jeunesse on va
parler de tout ça mais sur le 49-3 je
voudrais vous faire réagir là-dessus
Ariane oui non mais bon déjà il y a pas
que les jeunes qui se mobilisent je
pense pas que on puisse miser sur le
fait que les jeunes vont changer d'avis
en grandissant on voit en fait que la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites elle dépasse largement les
jeunes il y a la majorité du monde du
travail de la population qui est contre
et qui continue d'être contre et ça il
faut le comprendre et le 49-3 la
question c'est pas le terrain de la
légalité je suis au courant en fait que
le 49-3 c'est un dispositif légal de la
constitution de la 5e République mais la
réalité c'est que c'est pas pour autant
que c'est légitime quand il y a 3
millions et demi de personnes dans la
rue quand il y a 93% des actifs qui sont
contre la réforme des retraites quand il
y a des milliers et milliers et milliers
de jeunes qui non seulement sont dans la
rue mais qui sont aussi dans les
assemblées générales qui portent en fait
une aspiration d'avenir qui n'est pas
l'avenir que nous premier manuel Macron
et qu'ensuite il passe en force à
l'Assemblée nationale mais pire que ça
il nous réprime avec en fait la police
devant nos blocus lycéens devant nos
blocus universitaires qui vient nous
tabasser dans les manifestations désolé
mais ça peut être un dispositif pour
autant mais évidemment mais bien sûr les
jeunes ils sont entassés dans les
commissariats quand on regarde la braven
qui roule sur un étudiant en BTS quand
on voit en fait les témoignages de ces
étudiants à Nantes qui ont été agressés
sexuellement parce qu'elles ont allé
bloquer un périple dans le cadre de la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites quand on voit les témoignages
de ces étudiants dans le complément
d'enquête France 2 je pense pas que ça
soit des factieux comme le faire croire
le gouvernement la réalité c'est que la
mobilisation de la jeunesse elle est
très profonde que nous on s'est mobilisé
y compris contre la dérive autoritaire
d'un gouvernement qui passe en force une
réforme qui est détestée et en réalité
comme il a peur d'une jeunesse qui se
mobilise à la fois il manie la carotte
avec les 37 euros de bourse le rendement
on va faire
ce que vous avez dit
notamment
a commencé par dire que il y a on
tabasse les jeunes dans les
manifestations pardon de vous le dire
mais moi je vous enregistrement toutes
les violences ce que vous n'êtes pas
capable de faire toutes les violences et
en premier lieu celles qui sont commises
par les manifestants parce qu'un
manifestants n'a pas à être violent
j'aimerais aussi que vous me disiez
combien il y a de force de l'ordre qui
ont été blessés depuis le début de ce
conflit 1200 1200 forces de lois qui ont
été blessés j'aimerais aussi qu'on dise
que quand les forces de l'ordre
commettent des choses qu'elle ne doivent
pas commettre et il y en a et ça il faut
le reconnaître on l'a vu et les vidéos
dont vous parlez tout le monde les voit
donc évidemment qu'on les constate aussi
il y a des enquêtes qui sont ouvertes et
dire que les forces de l'ordre ne sont
jamais sanctionnés c'est faux pas moins
que les nerfs pas plus tard que l'année
dernière c'est plus d'une centaine de
sanctions il y a déjà 50 ou en quête qui
ont été ouvertes lors de ces
manifestations il faut peut-être un peu
d'équilibre dans le propos si on veut
parler à tout le monde et moi je
condamne les violences d'où qu'elles
viennent et notamment lorsqu'elles
commencent par celles des manifestants
parce qu'ils ne sont pas légitimes à les
faire je suis désolé de vous le dire
vous pouvez jouer aux révolutionnaires
dans la rue je croyais exciter les
tensions de certains mais à la fin vous
n'avez aucune légitimité à faire œuvre
parce que je viens de dire je viens de
dire que je condamne évidemment les
dérives lorsqu'il y en a mais ce qu'il
faut aussi d'abord avant tout condamner
c'est les violences lorsqu'elles
viennent de manifestants parce que elles
ne sont pas légitimes au-delà de ça sur
la dérive autoritaire pardon de vous le
dire nous sommes le 11 avril il y a un
an le 10 avril 2022 Emmanuel Macron
était en tête du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle avec 28% des
voix 28% des voix c'est-à-dire 2
millions d'électeurs de plus que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui aujourd'hui se
prétend légitime à mener une
contestation il a été réélu président de
la République ensuite qu'il y ait des
désaccords sur certains sujets c'est le
cas je peux vous dire qu'on est
majoritaire dans le pays sur la réforme
des retraites je suis pas aveugle et
personne ne l'est par contre ça ne
justifie pas des slogans qui consistent
à dire que le Président de la République
serait dans une attitude dictatoriale ou
toritaire c'est faux en fait il y a rien
qui ne juste qui justifie tout le monde
le voit enfin tout le monde le voit
c'est quoi tout le monde
c'est autoritaire quand on le Conseil de
l'Europe Amnesty International l'ONU
s'inquiète des violences policières
la mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites ça aide quoi interrogé quand
on voit que l'année dernière
effectivement pendant les élections
présidentielles les jeunes ils se sont
obtenus à 40 % et ensuite
majoritairement il vote à gauche la
réalité c'est que Macron il a été élu
par 12% de la jeunesse c'est rien le
point levé on fait plus dans les
élections étudiantes quand on se
présente dans les universités donc non
il n'y a pas quoi cette absence parce
que en fait nous on ne pense pas que on
puisse donner légitimité à Macron ou à
des candidats comme ça qui en fait sont
en train de construire non seulement un
avenir de misère pour la jeunesse mais
pas vu la voix y compris à l'extrême
droite parce que c'est ça parce que
c'est pas un peu contradictoire de ne
pas aller dans les urnes quand vous êtes
appelés à voter et après de dire il y a
pas de légitimité
on a bien compris que les acquis ils
s'acquèrent dans la rue et on voit bien
qu'en fait quand on se mobilise contre
la réforme des retraites quand on porte
des revendications contre l'autorité
l'autoritarisme de Macron contre la
sélection contre la précarité c'est là
où Macron effrayé par la mobilisation de
la jeunesse il fait un petit pas de côté
avec la réforme des rebourses et il
renonce au SNU il faut pas il faut pas
se lever je finis il faut pas il faut
pas se leurrer quand en fait les jeunes
avec Macron ils disent finalement
regarder nous on a fait 37 euros
d'augmentation des bourses en plein en
plein mouvement contre la réforme des
retraites la réalité c'est que c'est pas
monsieur mes gens qui c'est le la main
sur le cœur c'est en fait c'est en fait
la réforme des retraites elle est elle
dans la jeunesse évidemment il préfère
donner quelques miettes à la jeunesse
parce que c'est totalement insuffisant
plutôt que de tout perdre à l'arrivée si
vous savez bien que à un moment donné va
falloir payer la facture et que la
facture elle sera chouette je crains de
vous décevoir et de décevoir ce parmi
vous qui pensent que les mobilisations
et notamment celle violente permettent
d'obtenir quoi que ce soit la réalité de
la réforme des bourses elle inscrite
dans le calendrier du président de la
République depuis sa réélection nous
avons travaillé nous à l'affaire
inscrire dans son programme présidentiel
je suis pas sûr que ça soit le point
levé ou que ce soit certains collectifs
étudiants qui est convaincu le président
de la République d'inscrire ce texte
dans son calendrier je suis pas sûr non
plus que vous ayez défini le calendrier
d'ouverture des dossiers de bourses qui
comme chaque année tombent en mars et
donc les annonces sont en mars il y a
rien de nouveau à ça vous n'avez
absolument pas contribué à ça d'ailleurs
les organisations syndicales étudiantes
dans lesquelles vous êtes et auquel vous
êtes proche dans lesquels vous êtes
proches défendent absolument pas une
revalorisation des bourses elle
défendent une allocation d'autonomie à
1200 euros par mois
en attendant en attendant
la rue nous obtenons des avancées qui
sont extrêmement concrètes 500 millions
d'euros par an de revalorisation c'est
absolument inédit ça n'a jamais été fait
dans l'histoire du système de bourse et
ça va continuer puisque la réforme des
bourses il y a une deuxième partie qui
arrive et j'invite tous ceux d'entre
nous de notre génération qui veulent
participer à ça à rejoindre les travaux
qui sont fait de manière constructive
par certains syndicats je pense
notamment
à vous mais les 37 euros d'augmentation
de bourse mais c'est risible
ça dépend non alors ça de l'inflation il
y a aucune revente et par ailleurs il
faut croire il faut voir
les Banques Alimentaires parce qu'il y
en a plus aujourd'hui qu'il y en avait
pendant le covid c'est des non boursiers
c'est des non boursiers parce qu'en fait
il y a 56 % des étudiants qui mangent
pas alors il y a 56 % des étudiants qui
mangent pas à leur fin donc en fait on
peut pas vous êtes conscient de la
réalité mais de cette réalité mais vous
l’organiser consciemment consciente
aucun gouvernement
mais c'est faux enfin vous voyez bien
que vous racontez n'importe quoi vous
dites déjà que c'est en dessous de
l'inflation
c'est combien cette année
ça dépend vous prenez l'inflation
alimentaire c'est autour de 16%. les
prévisions de l'inflation pour cette
année c'est autour de 6 et 7% d'accord
revalorisation elle se fait à hauteur de
presque 7% sur les jetons de bourse mais
supérieur supérieur ça veut dire que sur
les champs de bourse inférieurs qui
concernent un tiers des boursiers c'est
pas rien un tiers des boursiers c'est
plus de 300000 étudiants sur ces
étudiants là enfin c'est 250 000
étudiants sur ses étudiants là c'est 34%
d'augmentation parce que juste pour le
rappeler quand même le montant des
bourses c'est ça a été revalorisé de 37
euros par mois c'est absolument inédit
simplement parce que ça n'a jamais été
fait genre je veux dire je et accessoire
on ajoute en plus des boursiers parce
qu'on est conscient de ce que vous dites
et pour le coup peut-être
barème pour la première fois depuis 10
ans vous adresserez au gouvernement
précédent notamment socialiste qui n'ont
jamais été revalorisés le barème pour
faire rentrer des boursiers dans le
système ce qui n'avait jamais été fait
depuis 10 ans et on va faire le point
avec Alex justement sur ces autres
mesures prises par le gouvernement mais
justement alors c'est peut-être une
coïncidence de calendrier mais le fait
est en ce moment et bien le gouvernement
envoie beaucoup de signaux en faveur de
la jeunesse alors on va parler du s&lu
le service national universel au
printemps le président de la République
devait annoncer une généralisation pour
tous les jeunes de ce SNU qui comprend
je le rappelle notamment en stage de
deux semaines en internat avec uniforme
un sneu qui est pour l'instant
facultatif et sa généralisation
finalement pour être reportée à une
échéance plus lointaine pour éviter
notamment de braquer la jeunesse en ce
moment écoutez la ministre en charge du
dossier Sarah et la GRI qui défend
malgré tout ce service national
universel à aucun moment le service
national universel n'est un projet pour
pour diviser au contraire il est censé
construire de la résilience de l'unité
de la nation et donner les moyens aux
jeunes les plus défavorisés les plus
éloignés et bien de vivre la France de
l'intérieur de construire un commun moi
j'ai toujours présenté deux hypothèses
que j'ai préparé une qui généralise sur
le temps scolaire et une qui crée allez
plus une généralisation par
l'attractivité avec des hypothèses de
reconnaissance de l'engagement et les
deux nous sommes en train des expertiser
et voilà donc on comprend que deux
options sont toujours sur la table
concernant ce SNU soit la généralisation
soit des mesures incitatives pour
s'engager dans ce service national
universel concernant les étudiants
effectivement le gouvernement a annoncé
une hausse du financement des bourses
étudiantes une hausse de 500 millions
d'euros qui feraient selon le
gouvernement en moyenne hausse de 20% de
ce budget écoutez la ministre en charge
de l'enseignement supérieur Sylvie
Retailleau un demi milliard d'euros mis
sur la table en effet pour les bourses
étudiants c'est une augmentation juste
historique et vous avez raison de
prendre un petit peu comme référence
parce que c'est important pour les
étudiants l'inflation sur l'alimentation
cette inflation aujourd'hui elle est
forte une inflation globale de 6%, mais
sur l'alimentation de plutôt 15 et on a
une réponse à 20% donc vous voyez je
pense que on répond et puis on pérennise
le repas à 1 euro pour tous les
étudiants boursiers et tous les
étudiants précaires et puis d'autres
mesures en faveur des jeunes pour être
annoncées le gouvernement prévoit
d'abaisser à 17 ans ou présent l'âge
pour accéder au permis de conduire une
mesure qui ferait partie d'un plan en
faveur de la jeunesse que la première
ministre annoncera avant l'été avec par
exemple des billets de train moins cher
ou une simplification du versement des
allocations logement un plongeon qui
était prévu avant la mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites mais qui
tomberait à pic dans cette période de
contestation
qui sont prises quand même par ce
gouvernement moi ce que je vois c'est
que effectivement il y a une
revalorisation des bourses de 37 euros
comme je le disais la réalité c'est que
la précarité étudiante elle ne va pas se
résorber parce que on a 37 euros par
mois en plus pour vivre à leur même que
précisément les études en précaires
c'est ceux qui sont le plus touchés par
l'inflation alimentaire sur les biens de
première nécessité sur l'augmentation
des factures etc etc et encore une fois
comme je le disais la réforme des
bourses elle n'arrive pas par hasard
comme si en fait on s'était levé un
matin et que finalement Macron dit oh
mon dieu je vais aider des petits
étudiants pauvres dans les universités
c'est que c'est évidemment une réponse à
la mobilisation qu'on arrive en retraite
c'est pas moi qui le dit vous le dites
aussi et ensuite sur la question du
service national universel moi ce qui me
frappe et c'est les propos qu'on a
entendu là mais c'est aussi les propos
que vous pouvez tenir sur d'autres
plateaux télé c'est à quel point le
gouvernement est incapable d'assumer le
fond de cette réforme là quand on les
écoute on a l'impression que finalement
le SNU ça serait quelques champs de la
Marseillaise quelques pompes et quelques
levées de drapeaux et puis finalement
c'est une petite colonie de vacances en
plein air ça ça fait plaisir mais ça
n'est pas du tout ça la réalité c'est
que le SMU c'est une entreprise de mise
au pas des jeunes ou en fait on nous
demande d'être formés à être docile à
être sage à être silencieux il y a un
certain nombre de jeunes qui ont
expérimenté le SNU qui sont carrément
tombés dans les pommes il y a eu des
expérimentations où ils ont carrément
simulé des fusillades il y a une
trentaine de jeunes qui s'est retrouvé à
l'hôpital tellement ils étaient
traumatisés par ce SNU là et aujourd'hui
vous venez dire sur les plateaux télé
que ce serait une colonie de vacances
mais si vous voulez vraiment organiser
ça dans le pays allez faire le BAFA je
pense que ça plaira davantage à tout le
monde la réalité c'est que les jeunes
ils ont raison de se mobiliser contre le
SNUI et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
vous avez renoncé à son application ici
et maintenant vous avez renoncé en tout
cas parce que vous voyez bien que la
réforme des retraites elles mobilise la
jeunesse au-delà de la question de la
réforme sortir des caricatures
évidemment les jeunes qui participent au
service national universel aujourd'hui
sont plutôt enclins et de satisfaits
puisque ce sont des volontaires mais il
n'empêche que le taux de satisfaction
est de 95% en sortie de SNU donc c'est
que ça doit être un peu différente ce
que vous décrivez d'ailleurs moi j'ai
jamais parlé j'ai jamais 95% de Tostat
satisfaction c'est aussi ce qui en
ressort moi j'ai jamais parlé de colonie
de vacances je crois que le service
national universel il a plusieurs
mérites le premier mérite et celui pour
lequel je le défends intrinsèquement
c'est qu'il est d'abord un vecteur de
mixité sociale qui quoi qu'on en dise ne
peut jamais être fait par l'école parce
que vous ne permettrez jamais à des
jeunes mahorés de rencontrer des jeunes
ce que vous cherchez c'est le conflit de
manière permanente et donc le fait que
des jeunes qui ne se connaissent pas qui
ne viennent pas du même milieu puissent
se rencontrer vous ne l'acceptez pas
parce que ça dessert votre projet
politique nous ce qu'on fait on le fait
pour que il y a une cohésion dans notre
société et pour la reconstruire là où
vous cherchez à la faire je pense qu'il
y a jamais autant de cohésion dans la
jeunesse que dans les manifestations
contre la réforme des retraites
je pense que la mobilisation
ça ça permet de créer pas mal de
cohésion après moi ça me présente toute
la jeunesse non mais écoutez il y a les
jeunes massivement dans la rue et
d'horizon d'horizon totalement différent
totalement différent quand on voit que
Assas Paris Dauphine
mais la réalité c'est que vous parlez
pardonnez moi mais vous parlez de mixité
sociale mais vous avez fait une école à
30000 euros l'année en moyenne donc
excusez-moi de vous dire mais si vous
êtes sensible
vous répondre de manière très simple oui
j'ai fait une grande école et j'en suis
assez fier globalement parce que je
viens absolument pas les moyens de la
plupart des jeunes dans le pays du
collège public j'ai fait j'ai fait le
lycée public à Tournon-sur-Rhône en
Ardèche je suis pas sûr que il y a
beaucoup de gens qui en venant d'Ardèche
et puis accéder à une grande école j'en
suis assez fière parce que vous voyez
moi mon école de commerce je l'ai pas
payé parce que mes parents avaient de
l'argent je suis désolé de vous décevoir
je l'ai payé avec un prêt étudiant que
je rembourse encore tous les mois et je
n'ai pas payé parce que je venais d'une
classe favorisée donc désolé de vous
décevoir ça arrive évidemment c'est
minoritaire très minoritaire et c'est
aussi le sens de mon combat et je dis
pas que la réussite passe par le fait de
faire des grandes écoles je dis juste
que vous avez une vision absolument
caricaturale qui consiste à enfermer des
gens dans des cases et aujourd'hui c'est
quand même paradoxal de vous entendre
dire ça quand on voit que une partie de
la mobilisation étudiante ça pue quand
même sur des lycées comme Henri IV ou le
lycée racine dans le 8e arrondissement
de Paris qui sont pas les endroits les
plus défavorisés donc si on peut sortir
de la caricature qui consiste à dire
vous avez fait ça donc vous ne pouvez
pas parler je pense qu'on grandira dans
le débat après
peu de temps
sur la question du s&u parce que encore
une fois la réalité et c'est ce que
disait Macron dès 2017 il la redit il y
a quelques mois en 2022 c'est que le SNU
ça n'est pas uniquement un séjour de
cohésion c'est ouvrir la voie à une
rabbitation d'une forme de service
militaire et un moment où il y a le
retour de la guerre avec la guerre en
Ukraine mais ce n'est pas vrai
d'autant plus de conflits
géopolitique dans dans le monde et
évidemment qu'on veut faire de la
jeunesse la chair à canon des politiques
impérialistes de la France à l'étranger
et c'est même Macron qui le disait il y
a quelques mois c'est que la guerre en
Europe c'est c'est aux jeunes qui
devrait le payer avec 10 secondes
d'un régime soviétique
aucune vocation militaire et vos
caricatures n'y changeront rien
et ce sera le mot de la fin vous restez
avec nous on va regarder ce qu'elle a
une de nos quotidiens régionaux avec
Alex Moussa
[Musique]
et Alex à la Une de La Provence et de
Var-Matin les recherches qui se
poursuivent après ils font
l'effondrement d'immeuble la rue de
Tivoli à Marseille oui toute une ville
est dans l'attente du Bellan définitif
de ce drame à la Une de La Provence
Marseille meurtrier à la Une de
Var-Matin après l'effondrement de cet
immeuble dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi les premiers corps ont été
extraits des décombres hier par les
secours de Marseille l'effondrement
n'est pas du et bien un immeuble
insalubre comme dans le drame de la rue
d'Aubagne en 2018 mais bien à une
explosion de nombreuses familles du
quartier ont été évacuées et sont en
cours de relogement la solidarité
s'organise dans la cité phocéenne pour
et bien aider les sinistrés et puis
autre drame ce week-end en Haute-Savoie
une avalanche à emporter six personnes
dans le secteur du glacier d'armandset
parmi eux un couple du Rhône qui laisse
quatre orphelins de 7 à 16 ans c'est à
la une du Progrès de Lyon une violence
contre une élue c'est elle a une
Corse-Matin oui l'adjointe au maire
d'Ajaccio Simone Guérini a vu sa maison
incendier un incendie criminel
revendiqué par le GCC les jeunesse
indépendantistes cors c'est un nouveau
groupe
aux incendies qui vont arriver cet été
dans le bassin d'Arcachon
potentiellement et notamment après un
été 2022 catastrophique au final les
comptes ont été faits et bien 27000
hectares ont brûlé depuis l'été dernier
dans les Landes de Gascogne et puis on
va regarder une intéressante du journal
La Voix du Nord sur le troc de graines
et oui les passionnés de jardinage se
réunissent de plus en plus dans ce qu'on
appelle les graines au Tex ce sont des
lieux pour échanger des graines n'auriez
pas regardé c'est un sujet intéressant
voilà c'est passionné de jardinage il y
a de plus en plus de gré de graines au
TEC notamment dans le département du
Nord ça permet de préserver la
biodiversité face à une standardisation
des semences à cause de l'industrie je
sens que vous allez vous lancer
je vois que ça vous impressionnait merci
beaucoup Alex merci Ambroise mes gens
merci beaucoup Ariana némoignanise
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce débat
prochain rendez-vous 18h Thomas Hugues
France public et nous on se retrouve
demain très bonne journée
[Musique]